[موسيقى]
حتى الرقم سبعه الذي يرمز عالميا الى الحظ
كان شؤما على السوريين الذين ضربهم مع
الاتراك زلزال تركيا والشام بسبع فاصله
سبع من درجات رختر التي ابادت قولا عن
بكره ابيها واهتز لها لبنان وقبرص وشيء من
الاردن والعراق لكن لا مصابا كمصابك يا
سوريا فتركيا ورغم الموت الجماعي والدمار
الهائل فيها لكن فيها ايضا دوله تستنفر
الداخل والخارج لملمه اثار الكارثه اما في
سوريا النظام والمعارضه فالمعاون المتوفره
هناك هي للهدم فقط وليس للنجده براميل
البارود لا تقابلها معدات انقاذ والقريب
والغريب يجيد قصفها ولا يجيد اسعافها
ما لنا غيرك يا الله ترنيمه الشعب السوري
الخالده طبعت على شواهد قبور ضحايا حروب
الديموغرافيا والايديولوجيا واستراتيجيا
وصولا الى الجيولوجيا تسمع الان الينا
خافتا من تحت ركام يدفن الاحياء ولا يستر
سواتنا عربا وعجما وبشريا ما لنا غيرك يا
الله الى العناوين
هؤلاء كانوا يعلمون ان الزلزال سيضرب
تركيا والشام
هل ان زلزال سوريا وتركيا هو عقوبه من
الله ولمن
صار لي بدو تسخر من ضحايا الزلزال وتدعو
الى القتل
امريكا تفض من طادا صيديا فترتفع حراره
الحرب البارده
وزير خارجيه اسرائيل من السودان ها قد
عدنا يا قمه الخرطوم
قيس سعيد يصل الى مرحله الكيماوي في حربه
على المعارضه
هل ستصدر مصر الكلاب الضاله لبيعها
بالعمله الصعبه
[موسيقى]
ويل
وجوه وين
وادي بيني وبين
وين
مرحبا انها بلده جندريس السوريه في ريف
مدينه حلب لم يقصفها الطيران الروسي ولا
طيران الاسد لكن مشاهد الدمار والموت
تتشابه فيما تتعدد الاسباب جندريس واحده
من قرن سوريه وتركيه اخفاها زلزال كهرمان
مراس او قهرمان مرعش الاعنف في التاريخ
الحديث عن الخارطه
يقولون ان سوريا تحولت منذ اكثر من عشر
سنوات من الفعل الى رده الفعل ومن الرياده
الى الارتداد حتى الزلزال جاء من الخارج
من تركيا التي توحدت ماساه شعبها مع
السوريين
لان الكوارث لا تعترف بحدود الجغرافيا ولا
تنتظر ترتيب اوراق السياسه من جنوب تركيا
الى الحدود السوريه تمتد كارثه طبيعيه
الانسان محورها زلزال بقوه سبع درجات
فاصله سبعه بمقياس ريختر يضرب المنطقه
متسببا في مقتل مئات الاشخاص واصابه
الالاف واضرار ماديه جسيمه لو انفقت كل
شركات هوليوود المليارات لما حصلت على هذا
القدر من مشاهد الذعر الانساني التي خلفها
الزلزال الثاني بولايه ملاطيا التركيه حيث
تحول مراسل تلفزيوني الى مسعف للمذعورين
زلزال الشامي وتركيا كان مفتوحا على اكثر
من زلزله وهزه تتبعها هزه واحيانا تحول
المنتشرون الى ضحايا منتسله
في سوريا صار عن نظامه الى ربط العجز عن
مواجهه تداعيات الزلزال المدمر بالعقوبات
الاقتصاديه الامريكيه فيما الامم المتحده
تجد الاعذار وتفند عوامل عرقله الاستجابه
لعمليات الغوث اما في تركيا فقد استعادت
مواقع اعلاميه تصريحات سابقه للرئيس
اردوغان اثناء كوارث مماثله يطمئن فيها
شعبه بان دولته لن تتركهم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بامكاننا
في ادلب لا تخف طفلنا الحبيب العالق بين
الركام فهناك من سيلقنك الشهادتين وشهاده
ثالثه على ضعف قوتنا وقله حيلتنا وهواننا
على الناس
[موسيقى]
اما رسول الله
في الزلزال الذي لم يقسم سوريا بين مناطق
نظام ومعارضه اباء وامهات يحتضدون اطفالهم
في مشهد العناق الاخير وام مهجره من دير
الزور الى ريف حلب تلد طفلها تحت الانقاض
ثم تودعه وتفارق الحياه مع بقيه افراد
عائلتها
لا شيء يعزي ذوي الضحايا الا التسليم
بقضاء الله تذكرون الطفل المغربي ريان
الذي حزن العالم لموته في حادثه البئر
الشهيره التي كانت زلزالا صغيرا على مقاصه
ولد اخ له هذا الاسبوع اسعد والديه الحياه
تستمر لكن الوالدين لم يقويا على تسميه
الطفل الجديد بريان تهيبا لذكراه الاليمه
فرحه جديده يعني
ربي حبيب عاود
الحمد لله ربي يحب يفرحنا ورزقنا بوليده
اخر
الله يرحمه يقدر يسمى
كان يعلم ان الزلزال سيقع واخبر الجميع
عنه بتغريده في موقع التويتر انه الباحث
الهولندي في شؤون الزلازل فرانك هوجر بيتس
حذر من وقوع زلزال تركيا والشام قبل ثلاثه
ايام من حصوله وبدقه كبيره شملت تحديد
المناطق وقوه الضربه على مقياس ريختر لكنه
لم يحدد التوقيت فالعلم لم يتوصل بعد الى
هذه الميزه يؤكد استاذ الجيولوجيا في
جامعه قطر سيف الحجري رغم الابحاث الكبيره
والكثيره التي انفقت عليها المبالغ الى
الان لم يتوصل للانسان الى تحديد بالضبط
الوقت
والدقيقه واليوم في في هذه الجانب ولكن ان
يحدد مناطق ذات النشاط الزلزالي الناس
يطول اعلامي والاغاثي السوري عمار الاسود
نشر قبل شهر تغريده عن زلزال متوقع في نفس
المناطق بتركيا وسوريا ولم يكن يعلم ان
هذه التغريده هي ورقه نعوته حيث قضى مع
زوجته في الزلزال خبران نبداهما بالايجابي
لتسونامي يعقب الزلزال اما السلبي فلا
تعتقد ان الزلزال ذهب بعيدا قد يظهر مجددا
في نفس مداره من الان وحتى السنوات
الثلاثه القادمه بحسب الباحث التركي
ليفانت جولين بهذه الشده ستكون له وهزات
ارتداديه تستمر لعده سنوات هذا طبيعي جدا
لا يوجد خطر تسونامي
هل الزلازل دليل على ذنوب العباد ومعاصيهم
هل هي عقوبات لهم كما يسارع البعض الى
التاكيد وبعض اخر الى النفي واحيانا الى
السخريه سئل الشيخ عبد الرحمن السند واجاب
بان اسباب الزلازل الطبيعيه وطبيعي جدا
الا نفصلها ايضا عن رسائل من الخالق
لعباده هذه الظواهر الطبيعيه لها اسباب
طبيعيه ولها اسباب شرعيه والزلازل
والبراكير والخسوف والكسوف من هذا الباب
من باب تخويف العباد ولا يقطع بانها
عقوبات او بسبب ذنوب وسيئات لكنها من
الايات التي يخوف الله بها العباد
للمؤمنين
فيكون التخويف هذا
لزياده ايمانهم
وتوبتهم ورجوعهم
ولغير المؤمنين ليكون حجه عليها ونخوفهم
فما يزيدهم الا طغيانا كبيرا الداعيه
البروفيسور عمر عبد الكافي لم يبتعد عن
هذا التفسير ودعا الى تفكر الاحياء في
الحكمه والموعظه من كوارث الجيولوجيا لابد
ان حركه الارض تلك انما هي من بعد ان تكون
ابتلاء شديد هي عباره عن تذكير لنا جميعا
بان الانسان يجب دائما ان يكون على
يعني استعداد للقاء الله في اي وقت فتخيل
انت هذه الدرجه التي
عبرت السابعه على مقياس ريختار حدث هذا
فنسال الله السلامه عندما تزلزل الارض
زلزالها الداعيه الشيخ عثمان الخميس
لم يفصل بين كوارث الطبيعه وذنوب الناس
التي تتسبب بوقوع البلاء الذي يذهب
بالصالح والطالح فبما كسبت ايدي الناس
فهذا قطع يقينا ان جميع ما يقع في هذه
الدنيا من الزلازل والبراكين بما كسبت
المصائب بشكل عام بما كسبت ايدي الناس
قطعا طيب لكن يبقى ان ليس المقصود ان كل
واحد كل واحد من الناس لكن في ناس تسببوا
في هذا
[موسيقى]
اما قد يكون صالحين ويصابون لان هؤلاء مع
الجمع تكون الاصابه عامه لكن هؤلاء يكون
لهم اجرا ويكون لهم تكفيرا لذنوبهم
واختبار لهم واولئك تكون لهم عقوبه طبيعي
جدا في كارثه انسانيه بهذا الحجم الا تجد
السياسه والعداوه مكانا لها بين جثث
الضحايا وعذابات الجرح والمشردين لكن الذي
جبل على الشر والحقد والبغضاء والتطرف
والارهاب والعنصريه والالحاد والضلال لن
تستطيع كل الزلازل والبراكين ان ترده الى
واحه الانسانيه مجله شارلي ابدو الفرنسيه
سيئه الصيت والسريره تنشر رسما
كاريكاتوريا للزلزال وتعلق عليه زلزال في
تركيا لا داعي لاخراج الدبابات اي لا لزوم
لقصف تركيا وتدميرها وقتل شعبها طالما ان
الزلازل تفعل ذلك في دعوه ولا اوضح ولا
اسرح ولا افضح ولا اوقح من هيك للقتل
الجماعي الذي لا يبقي ولا يذر علما انه في
مسيره زعماء العالم تضامنا مع ضحايا مجزره
صحيفه شارلي ابدو عام 2015 كانت تركيا عبر
وزير خارجيتها انذاك في طليعه المشاركين
المتضامنين
[موسيقى]
منطاد التجسس الصيني بالتوصيف الامريكي
استرق النظر على عورات الولايات المتحده
ففقاه سلاح الجو الامريكي وبمبدا العين
بالعين اصبح للصين دين واقرب مصرف لها
تايوان فهل رفع المنطاد من حراره الحرب
البارده بين واشنطن وبيجن التي تقول ان
المنطاد قد فض ظلما وعدوانا لانه مسالم
كمذيعات الطقس يرصد الاحوال الجويه فقط اذ
اطلق مسؤولون في البنتاجون اتهامات قالوا
فيها ان المنطاد الصينيه مصمم للتجسس على
مواقع عسكريه حساسه وجزء من اسطول تستخدمه
بكين في التجسس على خمس قارات حتى الان
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه تتخذ وضعيه وزاره
الخارجيه السوريه اي الاحتفاظ بحق الرد
وقالت الوزاره في بيان لها ان الجانب
الصينيه ابلغ الجانب الامريكي مرارا ان
دخول المنطاد المدني الى المجال الجوي
الامريكي كان غير مقصود بسبب ظروف قهريه
وتحتفظ بحق اتخاذ مزيد من الردود الضروريه
[موسيقى]
في مشهد يذكر بجنرال الاحتلال الفرنسي
جورو عندما وقف على قبر صلاح الدين في
دمشق وقال ها قد عدنا يا صلاح الدين وقف
وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيليه ايلي كوهين في
تل ابيب وقال لقد عدت من الخرطوم بثلاثه
نعم ناسفه للاءات الخرطوم الثلاث
والترجمه البسيطه لكل فلسفته هي الغينا
اللاءات وعدنا بنعم واحده للاحتلال عندما
عاد وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي الى اسرائيل
قال عدت ليس بنعم واحده وانما بثلاث نعم
للمفاوضات مع اسرائيل نعم للاعتراف
باسرائيل نعم للسلام مع اسرائيل ومن اين
من الخرطوم التي خرجت منها اللاءات الثلاث
عام سبعه وستين لا للمفاوضات لا للاعتراف
لا للسلام مع اسرائيل الخرطوم تستقبل
اليكوين وزيره خارجيه اسرائيل زياره بحثت
ملفات اقتصاديه وسياسيه النيه لكنها ركزت
في المقام الاول على ضروره استكمال ما
تبقى من اجراءات ملفي عمليه تطبيع التي
بدات مطلع فبراير عام 2020 بدل ان يجنح
السياسيون نحو الاستسلام لفكره التطبيع
ويرفضها العسكريون المقاتلون الذين ابتزوا
الامه العربيه نصف قرن وسلبوا الشعوب
حريتها تحت شعار لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت
المعركه
تنتهي الدعابه بان يصبح العسكر رواد
التطبيع وحجتهم الجديده لا مصلحه فوق
المصلحه الوطنيه المصلحه الوطنيه العليا
للسودان وحدها من دفع الجيش الذي يسيطر
على الحكم لهذه الخطوه كما يقولون وانهاء
حاله الاعداء مع اسرائيل اي مصلحه وطنيه
للسودان مع دوله الاحتلال وهناك اكثر من
اعتراف اسرائيلي موثق حول اشراف الموساد
على بناء وتسليح جيش نظامي لجنوب الانسان
كان يقاتل الجيش السوداني الرسمي قبل
انشاء دوله جنوب السودان التي احتفل
الانفصاليون باستقلالها بالعلم الاسرائيلي
الدقيقه الاولى من التاسع من يوليو تموز
يصبح جنوب السودان دوله مستقله رسميا
الامين العام للامم المتحده بانكيمون الذي
وصل الى جبال المشاركه في المراسم الرسميه
لاعلان استقلال جنوب السودان السبت شطر
شعب جنوب السودان فرحتهم جنوب السودان
انفصل تحت شعارات واحده بالتنميه والرقي
واذ به يبلغ دركا من الفقر والانحطاط
وتقاتل الميليشيات والعصابات واغتصاب
النساء وقهر الرجال استدعى معه نداء خاصا
من بابا الفاتيكان الى نبد العنف وحمايه
النساء في جنوب السودان زياره حط فيها
البابا الرحال وللمره الاولى بجنوب
السودان الذي يمزقه الاقتتال
زراعه منذ سنوات في بلد غالبيه مسيحيه
كاثوليكيه تحتل فيه الكنيسه مكانه هامه في
المجتمع انتم مدعون لتجديد حياه المجتمع
وتحويلها الى منبع خالص للازدهار والسلام
هل انت رئيس تونس قيس سعيد الليبيين معمر
القذافي رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله في
ليبيا خالد المصري لا يريد سعيد اخر في
ليبيا
ديكتاتور بكرافات المصري مثال واضح جدا
واحد جانب بديله على بعضهم في تونس اصبح
دكتور مستبد السلطه التشريعيه والتنفيذيه
والقضائيه حتى القضاء ضمه لي وقال قضاء
وظيفه بالسلطه الناس قبلين
بيدك يحولون خلاص
ممكن تعيدوا المقطع شباب
طيب يا اخي السيد الرئيس ما يعرفش يتكلم
كلمتين على بعض انتم ما علاقتكم وهل تبنى
البلاد بالكلام تبنى بالاقتصاد
صحيح ان السيد الرئيس لا يعرف ايضا
بالاقتصاد لكن الوطن ليس سوقا انه نسمه
حريه صحيح انه صادر الحريات لكنه سمح
للتونسيين بحريه الهجره صحيح ان السفارات
مش عم تعطي تاشيرات لكن من كان الرئيس
سعيد ايبحث عن سعاده في مكان اخر بهذا
العالم الرئيس قيس سعيد دشن طريقا جديدا
في البلاد وازال الستار عن لوحه تدشين
المشروع التي كان اسمه عليها اكبر من كل
الكلام الاخر بما فيه البسمله والتبرك ومن
هناك وبعد فضيحه مقاطعه تسعين بالمئه من
التونسيين للانتخابات يصف سيد المعارضه
بالخلايا السرطانيه التي يجب القضاء عليها
بالكيماوي
الف نعمه انه تونس مش دوله نوويه واليوم
يعني ما زالوا يريدون التنكيل ويريدون
التجويع مره للسكر مره موجود في الديوان
موجود اليوم السباح موجود في الديوانه
السكر والقهوه ولكن اطراف بطبيعه الحال
هذه الخلايا السرطانيه لابد من
الكيمياوي ربما عليها
[موسيقى]
تم تصنيفها على انها اغبى عمليه سرقه خلال
العقدين الاخيرين سمين ونحيف يشبهان حجما
وهاردي قررت تنفيذ عمليه سطو بمسدس
بلاستيكي على محل صرافه في مدينه الزرقاء
بالاردن
حاولت تنكر لكن الشرطه قبضت عليهما قبل ان
يتناولا طعام العشاء وابو عقال كفيه كمل
بالسجنه الغنيه
لازم اعرف مين اللي احبه وفتحت
خليته يوقع على الارض يا الكلب ايده ربطته
بالحبل
عضيته
مكتوب القبل
ولميت الجيران لبيت الجيران
عصاريف هيدا هي
دا
الساعه بالليل انا وحدي
ادخل الباب
عندي راسي
ليس فقط تيسوا الحرس الملكي البريطاني
الدوق ويليام يحمل رتبه عسكريه فهناك
الكثير من الضباط التيوس ذوي الرتب
العاليه في مختلف الدول
زيمبابوي ودعت رئيس بيلاروسيا الكسندر
لوكاشينكو بعرض عسكري تقدمه واحد من هؤلاء
الضباط الطيوس اذا كانت التيوس تطمع
بالمناصب العسكريه فان الكلاب قد تمسك
بالاقتصاد كلما اشتدت الازمه الاقتصاديه
في مصر تجدد نائبه اسمها رشا ابو شقره
المطالبه بتصدير الكلاب الشارده وبيعها
لمن ياكل لحومها في الخارج لجلب العمله
الصعبه في اجتهاد حسابي للنائبه بات يعرف
باقتصاد الكلاب ويمكن منها ندخل عمله خاصه
ان الارقام بتقول بناء على الارقام اللي
قدمتها النائبه رشا ابو شقره ان احنا
عندنا 12 مليون كلب ضال في الشوارع
المصريه ما الفرق بين تصدير الكبتاجون
وتصدير الكلب لاكله كلاهما حرام تقول
مديره الجمعيه المصريه لحمايه الحيوانات
والاهم الجانب الديني تصدير الكلاب كنا
احنا اكلها عندنا حرام فتصدرها لبلد تانيه
هم اللي هياكلوها حرام وده بيندهرج دينيا
تحت تجاره الخبيث والا كنا زرعنا بانجو
وحشيش وصدرنا الكوريا وظبطنا الاقتصاد
المصري وظبطنا الكوريين
[موسيقى]
ختاما ايميل دمركوس ارمله ديكتاتور
الفلبين الراحل فرديناند ماركوس على الرغم
من فقر شعبها المتقع كانت تطلب الطعام
طازجا بالطائرات من اوروبا وتهوى شراء
القصور حول العالم لا ينافس هوايتها هذه
الا متعه التسوق الفاحش وعشقها الابدي
للمجوهرات والتحف النادره
تعلقت بحقائب اليد وما تحتويه فاقتنت منها
الفا تتلائم مع الفين وسبعمائه حذاء فضلا
عن مئات الفساتين والمعاطف والمكملات جمعت
من القارات الخمس
تذكر الكتب ان ايميلدا الطاغيه عقيله
الطاغيه اقامت ذات مره حفله عيد ميلاد
لبعلها فرعون الفلبين لكن الغريب انها
امرت جميع اعضاء المجلس العسكري في البلاد
بحضور الحفله وهم يرتدون ثيابا نسائيا وقد
فعلوا ذلك جميعا دون تردد بعد سنوات على
الحفله التنكريه خلع الضباط ملابس النساء
فتحررت الفلبين من الاستبداد الى اللقاء
تتذكر من فتره من فتره مش من زمان
كنا نسافر من بلدنا لاي مكان
تتذكر ايه بتذكر ايه مش من زمان
كنا ناكل بالمطار ونشرب كمان
بحبك يا وطني احبك يا لبنان ايه لسه فاكر
كان زمان ماشي من زمان
[موسيقى]
واموالك نهب زعيمك بتحبه كمان
و زعيمك باقي حرامي بفضلك تمام
[موسيقى]
ليس فاكر كان زمان لا مش من زمان